DAVID JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to recitation.
As a warm up, let's get started
by computing some determinants
for 2 by 2 and 3 by 3 matrices.
Why don't you take some time
to work on computing these two
determinants, and when you're
finished, check back with me
and I'll show you
how I solved it.
Welcome back.
So why don't we get started
with the 2 by 2 matrix first.
So remember, when we compute
a 2 by 2 determinant,
we multiply the entries
in the main diagonal
and we subtract from that
the product of the entries
in the off diagonal.
So in this case, we
have 3 times minus 2,
minus, minus 4 times minus 1.
So we have minus 6
minus 4 is minus 10.
OK, now, the 3 by
3 matrix, we're
going to use a Laplace
expansion, which
means that we're going to need
to choose a row or a column
in the matrix.
We can choose any row or column,
but as I look at this matrix,
I'd like to choose
the first row,
because I see this 0 here,
which is going to mean
we have less work to do.
So let's do Laplace expansion
across the first row.
So what that means is we take
the very first entry, minus 1,
and now we need to
multiply it by a 2
by 2 determinant, which
we get by covering up
the row and the
column corresponding
to our first entry.
So our first entry was minus
1, and what we need to do
is cover up the row and
column containing that,
and we have this little
2 by 2 matrix here.
And so we get 2, 2; minus 2, 1.
OK.
The next entry, we have to
take negative of this entry,
but this entry is 0.
So minus 0 times--
just for practice,
why don't I put in this
cofactor here anyways.
So again, we cover up
the row and the column
containing the 0, and we
have this matrix 1, 2; 3, 1.
Now finally, we have
to walk over here,
and we have to take 4
times the minor-- which
we get by covering up the row
and column containing 4-- 1,
2; 3, minus 2.
And now notice that these
are just 2 by 2 determinants
and we can just compute those
the same way we did earlier.
Altogether, we get
minus 1, times 2
minus another 2-- excuse me, 2
minus-- 2 minus a negative 4,
so we get 6.
OK, this one goes away.
And then we have
plus 4, times, we
have minus 2 minus another 6,
so it looks to me like minus 8.
Altogether, we have minus 38.
Now let's just take a moment
to see what we did on the 3
by 3 matrix.
We needed to do a
Laplace expansion, which
means that we needed to
choose a row or a column.
And we needed to take
the entries of the row
and add these up, multiplied
by the cofactor matrix
we got by covering up the
row and column containing
our highlighted entry.
And we needed to do that
alternating the signs.
So we got minus 1
times this cofactor,
minus 0 times this cofactor,
and then finally, plus 4 times
this cofactor.
Altogether, we got minus 38.
OK, I'll leave it at that.
Thank you.